jean-marc semestre jean marc bonjour
alors la cour des comptes nous dit que
le coc vide a coûté très cher mais que
l'administration a aussi fait des
dépenses qui n'ont rien à voir avec
cette crise sanitaire
c'est un peu la découverte de la cour
des comptes parce que tout s'est passé
un peu comme si l'administration
française avait pris le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte d'emmanuel macron du coc
vide pour un open bar d'une certaine
façon alors en clair la france aurait
donc dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour
lutter contre le coc vide ça c'est habib
sy défi parce que ça a été efficace pour
amortir le choc notamment sur le plan
économique et social mais l'état a
chargé la barque en imputant qu'ovide
beaucoup de dépenses ordinaires qui sont
plus ceux liés aux fautes de gestion au
manque de prévision à la pression
politique ou mauvais fonctionnement de
l'administration en bref
l'administration aurait profité du kobe
pour justifier des accroissements de
dépenses qui est un peu dans sa nature
alors si on prend les comptes tels
qu'ils ressortent on va être prêt si on
veut pas en avoir trop la cour des
comptes dit que la crise synatel
sanitaire en tant que tel a coûté 92
milliards d'euros
mais le déficit total de l'état je parle
de déficit de l'état un pareil par deux
du déficit public de l'ensemble de la
france a été de 178 milliards d'euros
dont on a une différence 86 milliards
d'euros et bien cette différence est
imputable à un glissement des dépenses
ordinaires de l'état hors celui cement
est anormalement élevé par rapport aux
années précédentes
donc ça veut dire que l'administration
est allé au guichet coville pour assurer
son propre train de lui alors si
l'argent n'a pas servi aux convives 19 à
la crise donc à quoi at il été utilisés
alors il ya quand même beaucoup d'argent
qui a servi au vide mais les dépenses et
aux copies dont les connaître ces
dépenses là ni perte est de masquer
backs un fonds de solidarité chômage
partiel mais comme l'état avait prévu de
dépenser encore davantage il avait
demandé des crédits lors des lois de
finances rectificatives qu'il n'a pas
utilisé parce que ici à un peu trompé
dans ses dans ses prévisions donc
l'administration a profité à profiter de
ces surplus de crédit pour laisser
glisser sa dépense courante comme je
vous disais il ya un instant on a
continué à baisser les impôts sur les
sociétés comme cela avait été promis
lors de la campagne électorale on à gond
les effectifs de fonctionnaires et
beaucoup de dépenses ont été faites sans
lien avec la crise sanitaire des crédits
supplémentaires en profite et
majoritairement à la défense nationale à
l'écologie à l'enseignement dont 900
millions de dépenses de personnel en
plus on a aussi engagé ce qui n'était
pas prévu des investissements dans
l'avenir et des actions de solidarité
dont l'allocation adulte handicapé alors
tout ça est forcément légitime mais tout
ça n'était pas forcément inscrit dans
les lois de finances bref sur la
couverture de dépenses qu'ovide les
dépenses ordinaires vous le voyez les
ont beaucoup augmenté en profitant des
financements voter pour le coc vide mais
non utilisés pour cause de mauvaises
prévisions
quelles vont être les conséquences d'une
telle évolution
jean-marc merci a rempli sa mission en
finançant les effets de la crise
sanitaire
mais le fait que l'administration allait
profiter pour se remettre à grossir ce
qui quand même sa tendance est là une
tendance à l'obésité ça prouve que le
parlement ne siège à une hier les
opérations et c'est un peu ce que la
cour des comptes lui reproche et cette
dérive
eh bien elle est propre à agacer tout le
monde elle agace l'europe l'europe va
entamer une négociation pour ramener les
finances dans les clous de maastricht à
la france est assez mal placée pour
venir à apporter d'être son moral je
peux ajouter que cette situation
explique en partie la résistance des
allemands dans le financement du plan de
relance européen
il devait être mutualisés le salut au
niveau européen les contribuables
allemands disent est bien d'accord pour
voter un financement européen pour le
coc vide à condition que l'argent ne
soit pas utilisée ailleurs donc je pense
qu'on va avoir une sortie crise
compliquée dans la famille européenne
il va falloir régler la crise sanitaire
bien sûr finir de régler cette crise
c'est pas évident et puis il va aussi
falloir mettre deux sur la table et bien
une réforme de l'administration pour
éviter un dérapage continuelle des
dépenses publiques
jean marc sylvestre merci beaucoup pour
votre éclairage